on the night we celebrate jackie
robinson
and what he did we need to think about
what we can do
to make our sport and our country move
in the right direction
nice stuff tommy and last night the
marlins and mets really did a great job
amongst the two teams
gathering they did decide before the
game not an easy decision but they came
together and came up with a
what worked to be a very good plan i
thought for the two teams to come out
take the field
and then make their statement yes i
thought it was just
tremendous the way things all came
together
last night culminated by louis brinson
placing the t-shirt on home plate these
young people standing up and
athletes standing up so i they know that
there's a lot of work to be done
a jackie robinson day is not just about
a celebration
it's about you know remembering history
and understanding that major league
baseball did play a part in my dad
played a part in
opening up the doors but there's still
lots of work to be
done sanchez making his second major
league start the sixth best pitching
prospect in all of baseball number 18
overall in baseball and the best the
marlins have to offer right now
in their farm system austin meadows to
lead things off
and the pitch is outside and he's swung
and missed and he's down on strikes
strikeout number one for six doe sanchez
brandon lau who is putting together a
really special season here for the tampa
bay rays
and on 1-2 he goes back to that
change-up
he's got two strikeouts ryan yarbrough
taking the mound tonight for
the tampa bay rays here is corey
dickerson about to step
in and that's a little tap
he's gonna get it perez will make the
throw to first
and birdie moves up to second yarbrough
doesn't want to get hit with the throw
but michael perez never takes his eyes
off the prize
but now brian anderson
runner heads to third they're gonna
throw him out he is out birdie trying to
steal
third caught stealing for the first time
this year
so with one on that'll bring up willie
adamus
ball and two strikes senadamus swings
and misses again that change up
so three strikeouts all on that same
pitch holly already
now joey wendell sanchez deal swing and
a miss strike three and that's four
strikeouts now
for six doe sanchez all four on
change-ups
for michael perez to lead off against
sixto sanchez here in the third inning
no score
ball and two strikes and there's a
fastball a hundred miles an hour
already the fifth for six though
loud with a strikeout back in the first
inning that first time through for six
though five
k's they'll check down at third
and they say that he went around six
strikeouts
for sixto sanchez so with one out
that'll bring up lewis brinson and he
was the one that walked to the plate and
dropped the
the t-shirt on home plate yesterday was
quoted after the game obviously it meant
a lot to him
and uh was vocal and involved in the
players alliance
yesterday and that players alliance
donating their pay
to the jackie robinson foundation with
yesterday and today
hard hit ball and that's past diaz down
the left field line
brinson turns on his way to second throw
from meadows
not in time and it's a one-out double
for louis brinson
the g-man troy to start things off
against six though sanchez
one two detroit swing and a miss he blew
him away at 99
seven strikeouts for six though joey
wendell
a strikeout victim back in the second
steps in
oh he goes to it again sixto with
eight strikeouts through four well for
ryan yarbrough it is
all about missing the barrel of the bat
the name of the game
soft contact get your hand out of the
way of the catcher stepping too that
would help but that right there chase
the change up
occasional strikeout for yarbrough he
just wants to get it off the barrel
and that ties up cooper back door with
the cutter there
oh look at that line drive oh but it's
off the end of the bat that's the whole
name of the game and yarbrough's been so
good and he knows he has to be
watching sanchez [ __ ] from the other
side and he's working quickly and mowing
down raise hitters and ryan yarbrough
doing the same here against the marlins
the catcher
tapped in the ground toward third yandi
charging from the left of the mount
throws
and he got him nice play takes care of
alfaro but yandi
really showed some range there you know
a lot of times we think of range from
east to west and side to side at third
base because they're reactionary but a
lot of times range includes charging in
on those balls
layman diaz the first baseman
there it is there's a swing and a miss
by diaz
and there's out number two another
strikeout for ryan yarbrough no score
here on the bottom of the fifth is
pitchers keep putting up zero this is
the third time around
austin meadows the leadoff hitter
and he goes to the changeup again double
digit strikeouts for six doe
sanchez rojas grounded ashore his only
time
and right now the rates have a
three-game lead in the east
back doordoom with a cutter and that got
strike three called it's the fifth
strike out of the game
ryan yarbrough el faro
is a pitch away off the plate oh boy
and now we have an issue here with
yarbrough
it was instant too dwayne right after
the pitch
call has been made to the bullpen
they're not going to waste any time here
and
fairbanks who had been loosening in the
bullpen for the second time tonight
will make his way in because meadows
breaking out swinging twice and singling
sharply into right
so one for three two balls no strikes
the count two meadows in a scoreless
game of the eighth inning here it comes
swinging at a line drive to the gap
right center that gets down for a hit
meadows around first it's backhanded to
the alley by brinson and a huge turn by
meadows
now he goes back to first in the throw
not in time he's in there
brad boxberger the new pitcher with
yandy diaz batting
and a line drive base hit into the left
dickerson up with it
meadows will head to the plate and the
raids will take the lead one
nothing on the rbi single by yandi diaz
now michael perez is gonna be the hitter
and he shoots one into right field
that's gonna drop for a base hit
joyce plays it on one hop wendell
scores and the rays come up with another
big run
how about michael perez driving home
joey wendell from second
two minute on two men out jorge alfaro
will be the hitter
the ground ball third base wendell steps
on the bag and the rays are winners
it's a two-nothing final